hello and welcome to this video playing
me hmm
mission we don't know all right so our
his playing quickly he or she what what
the heck
you
let's move us probably five
this is this is hilarious
yeah not even try and dare to to think
that you that you think about your moves
again so yeah what is black about to do
and probably be five yeah that's it to
something simple
this is really funny
okay
all right so I don't see how this
it's with the rest of the the set up but
if like insists on doing d5 I do it
okay now c4 is good Bishop a3 is good
elegy for looks very logical attacking
the whole structure and just asking
black if you really can play without any
development or with this little
development okay now how do we handle
this him generally speaking I would like
to keep the tension down
to take
Tinku should be three
how do I keep the tension maybe Queen to
d3 and rook c1 okay thinking for quite a
long time here maybe this is just the
way it's Jo taking any time a black
we'll just play some something something
quick without any any big concept anyway
and if you have yeah spend so much time
you laying all the groundwork to to lose
on time okay 94 is probably the next
move by black so let's return yeah SC 5
is that something Knight to c6 probably
mmm
and this is not a bad move actually it's
all a bad move it all
see 596 sir I don't
have a great reply against this but
Quincy 3 is not really all that
attractive
now probably there is some 94 stuff or
other discovery okay
my my whole approach was not very
successful of course obviously
but my position is so okay I don't have
any problem let's aim
I mean the time situation is hilarious
yeah just like has just played instantly
the whole time
okay it's not a problem my position is
just a contagious
I got some some pressure here on the
e-file and it's not easy for like to
handle this situation I could have
actually taken on d5 and I can't do it
now the question is is it is it helpful
I'm not even so certain so I'm just
going to to go on go with this okay
my biscuity sh5 okay now I don't need
need age five maybe the media g4 I mean
I still have 30 seconds that is plenty
you
it's no need to rush stuff I could have
taken d5 I didn't like it so much though
because maybe black had some idea that
you to play bishops is six then
anyway I'm here I'm fine
yeah the big question is I mean I would
like to have more time to figure this
out but I don't have it just
20-something seconds if F 4 is right
timing it maybe it is too early as
possible
but in general it must be a decent idea
to break all this open maybe taking was
stronger but here is 6 is going to fall
he put the bishop on to c4 it was funny
decision because this is the worst
possible Square almost it doesn't defend
or help in any way so it's not it
doesn't make much sense honestly
so how where's the meat is this this
chick chick
yeah that was one of the funniest
opening stages I was like pre moves all
the way you're really funny okay so got
this
and yeah oh it's not a red line so
somewhat offbeat line but gaining the
space is quite quite useful and I'd be
g7 oh that was pre move rook b8 b3 I
expected b5 but black never played that
that makes some sense and this black
seems to be okay I mean it's it's pretty
much a non-contact opening and yeah it
cannot be anything special for either
side he played h6 though like instantly
in 98 yeah and this I don't quite
believe C 496 I probably did not exploit
that to the fullest
yeah Queen d3 I don't know probably that
isn't the best how came the engine wants
to take and here-here 95 it is very
sensor
putting enormous pressure here and
preparing f-for okay yeah and this one
there is actually this kind of sequence
then 94
probably I'm better with 23 or so but is
this but somewhere here I kind of lost
the plot we should be six and probably
92 was bad yeah I was worried by this
but moving backwards is not a good idea
I can take yeah I absolutely didn't see
that I have this move here this is very
important this this and then 95 this is
very nice for
pressure for four not much let's say I'm
not material down or have any other
problem yeah and here's snipey aid is a
good move and to makes things so
improves the situation for but I can
probably hear after this he's okay we
fire he's more than okay I kind of had a
hunch that there's something happening
here well II five so what is the deal I
had take it there is just D four of
course oh I'm sorry that was I miss
click Wow who won they have to take with
the night then avoid the fork but this
is obviously good for black
yeah yeah had a had this hunch that
Quincy three was somehow wrong but I
wanted to as actually psyllium
five which is probably simply
unimportant
but to see engine what the PlayBook cb1
what is that
ah okay I have this I do understand no I
didn't see this this thing okay yeah
after you missed that and now again he
five was good
here I'm I'm quite okay again yeah and
not no I'm I'm very satisfied because
this is just a bit of pressure for not
much and of course you know I saw that I
can take but I wasn't certain like what
I am what I wasn't certain about is if
he can activate with this but you know I
had just had a that was just one my
money i have t five again I mean yeah
and then I should just take the pawn and
you know okay I was just thinking I may
have pressure for for nothing let's say
and I mean the game was rather rather
one-sided I'm not certain about f4 okay
Queen c2 is killing I just go to g6 but
it should be him still a substantial
advantage I'm attacking with all pieces
and this is not doing anything I can
take whatever I should win as well no
it's okay I mean I made this this was a
bad a bad judgment the Queen to c3 even
after he did not exploit that it was a
fairly fairly good control that had okay
guys thanks for watching